Emily's with us in Texas
hi Emily welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey Dave thanks for taking my call um so
here recently in the last 15 months my
husband and I have been paying an
additional thousand dollars towards our
mortgage with the intentions of lowering
that balance well how however with in
support of the snowball effect we do
have a debt in front of that which is a
vehicle oh you would start to them yeah
so my question to you would be should we
be applying the additional payment they
were making to the mortgage into the
vehicle just knowing that the vehicle is
going to continue to depreciate in value
well if you're worried about
depreciating in value you should just
sell it not not keep debt only keeping
debt on it doesn't keep it from
depreciating right okay those things are
incongruent so if you're going to keep
the car you should pay it off as soon as
possible okay stop paying extra on your
mortgage I'm glad you're paying extra on
your mortgage I like the idea that you
know you're working towards getting out
of debt but the power of focus is what
has caused the system that we've used
for so long to work and meaning that
what you focus on you win at and so we
stopped doing everything except the baby
step we're on and in your case you're on
baby step 2 because you have a consumer
debt left to pay off I take it that's
your only debt yes that's the only debt
cool and how much do in the car 54,000
on my car
yes what's your household income
Mima hasn't combined 240 okay good what
do y'all do for a living we work in the
financial industry business or program
managers wonderful what kind of car is
in our Yukon oh we have three kids yeah
it's a family car it's very only family
car that we have so I mean I want to
tell you sell it you can you can you can
handle it at 240 it's just it's an
expensive car but you make a lot of
money so yeah let's get that paid off
you have any money saved anywhere that
is not in retirement accounts yes we do
have money in our savings account how
much
roughly 15,000 okay well if you've been
reading our stuff you'll find out real
quickly what we teach is and it's gonna
scare the crap out of you the kind of
money you make but is $1,000 as baby
step one and anything that is not
retirement assets any kind of investment
or cash position that is not in a
retirement account that would be
penalized has taken out to pay off all
debts in baby step two and so if I woke
up in your shoes it's gonna be hard for
you today if I woke up in your shoes I
would have $1,000 in my account and I
would take everything else and throw it
at this car and I'll get this stupid
butt car paid off and I mean within
three months four months maybe something
like that it needs to be done really
really fast
and once you're debt-free everything but
your home then you build your emergency
fund of three to six months of expenses
then you start investing fifteen percent
of your income by the way if you're
investing now you should stop that
temporarily until you get these other
two things done and that's the stuff
that we teach that's how we teach it
Emily
and so you guys are you guys are making
a lot of money but you're making way too
much money to have a $54,000 car line -
it's kind of just mathematically
financially lazy to have gotten that car
loan you make enough money to paid for
the car if you just saved up a little
bit and died
hey thanks for the call